nous sommes acura sow possession
néerlandaise de la mer des caraïbes et
satellite pétroliers du venezuela tout
proche
surnommé le paradis des coquettes dans
sa réglementation libérale du marché de
l'or et des bijoux
car il y à des gouvernements qui
emplissent leur caisse en multipliant
les taxes qu'ils aient d'autres en les
supprimant le gouvernement de curaçao a
choisi la deuxième solution que l'on ne
voit guère appliquée à travers le monde
que dans les pays de petites superficies
le très curieux on dirait que les bonnes
recettes fiscales produisent du déficit
au dessus de 1000 kilomètres carrés
quand je parle de paradis des coquettes
vous entendez bien que dans ce paradis
là aussi
il y a moins d'élus que d'appeler
nous sommes à dix mille kilomètres
d'amsterdam mais nous sommes encore en
hollande c'est à dire que nous vivons du
commerce qui n'a plus de secret pour
nous depuis des siècles
et que le premier de nos quotidiens
locaux
est un journal qui nous donne les
dernières nouvelles boursières du monde
entier
dans les îles sous-le-vent les anciens
frères de la côte
ont cédé la place aux frères de la coach
qui surveille le marché des valeurs au
lieu de supputer sournoisement la valeur
du march
nous vivons toute l'année dans la bonne
odeur qui s'échappe des usines où nous
raffinons le pétrole du venezuela
c'est à dire que nous nous éloignons de
plus en plus du folklore caraïbes pour
entrer dans l'ère du développement par
le relais de la station service
cependant bien que nous soyons
néerlandais c'est-à-dire ingénieux
travailleurs
équitable
bien que nos maisons
soient souvent cossu est solidement
hollandaise avec un rien d'exubérance
coloniale en sus
bien que notre quotidien préféré soit un
journal de bourse
il ne suit pas que nous ayons tous un
physique épanouie d'actionnaires à la
hausse
nous avons nos taux dit nos bas
quartiers nos enfants maigre dans ces
terrains vagues qui forment autour des
zones industrielles de tous les pays du
monde
de ces espaces indécis qui ne sont ni de
la ville ni de la campagne et que l'on
appelle précisément la zone
le
nous avons nos écoles qui ensemble à
toutes les écoles à cela près qu on y
apprend le pape y amène tôt
nous avons en théorie nos enfants des
écoles qui sont semblables à tous les
enfants de toutes les écoles
mais
nous avons aussi nos mauvais souvenir
telle cette ut d'esclaves conserver
comme un témoignage
une attestation d infidélité de l'europe
à sa propre morale chrétienne
et ses mauvais souvenirs ne sont pas des
souvenirs lointains
si vous n'êtes plus un enfant songez que
victor schoelcher le héros de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
aurait pu être grand-père le passé en
histoire c'est presque toujours hier
vous avez vu il ya un instant l'hôtel
hilton de curation qui regardent la mer
et tourne le dos à un certain nombre de
réalités
à
on
mais la promenade est finie
notre paquebot antilles hacker a fait
son plein de combustibles liquides
les sacs postaux leur plein de courriers
et sur le pont les passagers leur plein
d'image en deux semaines de rotations
entre la ligne des trois piques et le
sabre de feu de l'équateur ils ont vu
près le célèbre collier d'émeraude
que les grandes puissances sont
longtemps disputé à coups de fusil un
monde entre deux mondes
ces terres légères qui subissent
simultanément la traction de l'europe
les a mêlés à son histoire des
etats-unis dont l'emprise s'accentue par
le moyen innocent du tourisme et de
l'investissement
et de l'amérique latine qui tout près
d'elle sort en variante encore un peu du
long sommeil de la résignation
ils ont vu la france a la martinique
washington et son capital à porto rico
le grand canal d'amsterdam acura saut
ils auront vu aussi des antillais
certainement
mais un remorqueur a déjà passé un
anneau dans le nez du mastodonte qui les
chargeait de tirer vers la mer
la lente glissade a commencé le pont
tournant vrai s'ouvrir
est ce un bâtiment qui s'engage la
poursuite d'un insaisissable horizon où
le plus beau quartier de la ville qui
s'en va
oui
mais voici
à droite
la grande échancrure du large
renty va terminer sa croisière
sans nous
ils n'essuient bonne compagnie qui ne se
quitte
ma maman